- All right, I always like to end things
with a story to keep your spirits high.
So this is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
It's awesome how kids can be so mesmerized
by what seems like relatively
simple things to us grownups.
Just check out this little girl walking
by an impromptu photo shoot in New York.
(extravagant orchestral music)
(audience cheers)
- It's so adorable. (laughs)
I love it.
She was like, "I love this.
I love what you're wearing."
That's already been viewed
over 68 million times.
It's incredible.
(audience cheers)
And we have the woman who is wearing
that white dress dialed in right now.
Let's say hi to the very beautiful Monica,
who watches on NBC 4 Los Angeles.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Hi!
Well, first of all, you look
absolutely stunning then.
You look absolutely stunning now.
But tell us about that very
sweet moment. That was adorable.
- Yeah, I mean, it was so beautiful.
So I was in New York for a gala
for the Fifteen Percent Pledge,
which is a nonprofit organization
that encourages retailers
to have at least 15%
of their shelf space dedicated
to Black-owned businesses.
So I was excited to get dressed up.
We haven't been able
to do that in a while.
And so my friend wanted to
take pictures of me downstairs.
And at first I was telling her no,
that I didn't want people staring at me,
but I'm glad we did
because, you know, we
got some great photos.
And while we were taking
photos outside the hotel,
I noticed a dad and his
daughter were waiting
for me to finish taking photos.
And so I told him they can go
ahead and not to wait for me.
And the dad said that his
little girl might take a while
because she had her stroller and her doll.
But I told them they can go ahead anyways.
So, you know, she finishes her
walk and then the video kind
of picks up where she's finishing her walk
and she does a 180, which
I thought was so funny.
And then she, you know, she's
mesmerized by the dress.
I didn't expect her to be
looking so closely at them,
was the main thing.
And I thought it was so cute
that she had the Black baby doll, as well.
So it was just a very sweet
moment and a surprise.
- It was. It was so great.
And yeah, she was looking at the dress,
but you look so breathtakingly
beautiful in the dress, too.
And she was like, "What is this thing?
You are so beautiful."
I mean, she was just like,
"I gotta touch on this beautiful."
It's gone super viral,
so why do you think this has
resonated with so many people?
- I mean, I think the
way that I've taken it as
is I think a lot of people are put back
into that moment of when they're a child
and they're seeing a lot of
things for the first time.
And so I think it kind of reminds a lot
of people to keep that
child-like curiosity
about the world and approach things
as if you're seeing it for the first time.
You know, it was just the dress, as well.
The designer, her name
was Vivian Valerius,
and that dress combined
with just the sweet moment,
I think, was just very
exciting for people to see.
- It's so artistic.
Well, thank you so much, Monica,
for sharing that with us.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(heart dings)
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot, pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you ma'am,
so they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- That's amazing. Thank you so much.